leaving everyone with just past five
and we'll make a start before we move
into the meeting I just wanted to let
everyone know that afterwards if we can
go down the stairs by the coffee
platform because apparently there's a
quiz on in the atrium so unless you want
to sort of be part of a quiz
anyway it's moving on
Oh the other thing that I need to let
people know formally is that item 14 on
the agenda paper BCA 1939 has been
withdrawn this evening okay
apologies for absence thank you
declaration of interests by councillors
no declarations might be a silly
question but if we were parish counselor
do we have to declare no we don't okay
thank you
breakin right the next item on the
agenda is paper BCA 1932 confirmed the
minutes of the meeting that we had on
the 9th of January I just pull that up
here on my screen so going through that
does anyone have any issues over the
first page second page
third fourth page
so can I have a vote in favor of
accepting those minutes please all those
in favor
yep okay okay right
the next item then is paper BCA 1933 to
confirm the minutes of the second
meeting we had last month on the 16th of
January again first page second page
third page and fourth page any points
anyone wants to raise raised on those
minutes if not may have a vote please
all those in favor thank you right the
next item to receive notification of
petitions in the course for the
council's petition scheme next item
questions by councillors and the next
item met is referred by the overview of
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees I think right okay Castle
McCraw has given his apologies but
you'll see in your agenda pack that
there are some minutes from overview and
scrutiny that they're minded to approve
the budget general fund NHRA budgets and
and do thank the finance team for their
efforts and putting those together
the only other minute they have provided
here is on the the corporate plan
outputs and there's there is a
recommendation which will be taking as
part of the discussion and the debate on
that item later and the agenda and this
is to ensure that we've got a range of
methods in place to engagement members
and we'll be discussing that when we
cover this item
the next item forthcoming decisions list
which everyone will have got a link to
are there any questions regarding the
forthcoming decisions list
cansu Busby and it's doesn't actually
give me the list I can download it I
guess from there is a further on the on
the page you've got there gives another
link there is another link yes and you
can either download and save it or open
it immediately yeah this is becoming far
too complicated for a simple man like
myself do we actually need a new
decisions list every week but the more
often we get the less inclined I am to
read them entirely up to you with you
wish to read them or not we published
them when things are added to them so
that you've got the most up-to-date
position the reason why you've got to
click on another link which is
irritating I accept is because that
document changes and so if we took you
direct to the relevant PDF we know that
link will only be any good for the
relevance of that PDF document but by
going to the main link itself then you
will always be able to click on to the
most recent PDF we are by law required
to publish forthcoming decision lists in
relation to key decisions 28 days prior
to those decisions being sought so
that's why we have to publish it on a
regular basis to make sure particularly
relation to key decisions and
particularly relation to confidential or
proposed confidential decisions you have
a much broader forthcoming decision list
that covers
all things coming to cabinet and all
things going to council so that both
yourselves all counselors all members of
the public and scrutiny you can see
what's coming up in the forthcoming
period but if you don't look it's fine
while still having a general moment when
you send out a revised agenda can the
revised agenda include all the items not
just the bit that you've revised we've
now got kind of three emails to try and
find and and I hope you still every time
we log out of a paper it logs it's right
back to the the original email and we
have to come back into the the meeting's
agenda I mean it's just bring back paper
if if I can just check I look across to
my colleagues and um is everything
correct on modern gov yes
so if members use modern gov which is
the the source of all documents you will
find it it's constantly up-to-date okay
castle Davis still got the joint area
will have the joint area parking plan
we're not that good the leader withdrew
that at the beginning of the meeting and
not before we're efficient but we're not
that great okay
right everyone happy with the
forthcoming decisions list great thank
you very much moving on to the next item
then that's paper BCA 1934 the general
fund budget for 2020 to 2021 and the
four-year outlook okay right I'm not
going to go through a detailed report
because I did last time when we looked
at this last month and I will be again
at full council later this month so I
just want to go through some of the
changes that have taken place in the
budget since we last looked at it last
month so now in terms of both the the
latest document you've got and the the
new papers which are in the latest email
we're now looking at a general fund
budget that requires five hundred and
six thousand pounds of the 2020 to 2021
new homes bonus receipts 1.2 million
pounds of section 31 grants 227,000
pounds the rural service delivery grant
and two hundred and seventy eight
thousand pounds from our EMR reserves in
order to balance the budget we're now
using a 48% of the anticipating new
homes bonus and and the rest will be
transfer
transfer to the transformation fund the
overall budget gap now for the next four
years is a cumulative 1.1 million pounds
as shown in table night and table 9 and
but the good news is that we're now
predicting a surplus this coming year of
seven hundred and eleven thousand pounds
which is significant more an improvement
of 163 thousand pounds since we last
looked at this position last last month
there are a number of movements that
have been outlined in the amendment
which was sent to you earlier this week
I believe which which explains 163
thousand pounds difference five of them
relate to business rates following the
completion of the NMD our one returns
that was submitted recently we have a
full budget book now at appendix D for
2020 to 2021 and also revised fees and
charges scheduled for the forthcoming
year is provided in appendix E the
reserves again they're highlighted in
paragraph 7 point 5 table 3
thanks to the new homes bonus we've got
severe significant improvement to the
transformation fund it's now going to be
nine hundred and ninety four thousand
pounds as a result of that additional
one hundred sixty three thousand pounds
that I mentioned earlier we've got the
capital program again is set out in
Appendix B with the spend of eleven
point four million pounds and that is as
much as it was when we last looked at it
the only other thing that I want to draw
your attention to is section 12 with the
pay policy statement and that's
something obviously we're required to
each financial year under Section 38
paragraph 1 of the Localism Act 2011
so I'll open this up for debate and
questions but in the meantime I would
like to propose the recommendations in
paragraphs 3.1 to 3.5
for this this cup of forthcoming budget
so any questions anyone
councillor Davis I'm a question total
mess as a compliment because I think
when we looked at this budget as as well
as we did last year and we recognized
that we were going to have to increase
to to the maximum which we've done it's
five-pound now which as most we can do
but I have to say I think it's entirely
impressive for our finance team have
worked out the budget and over the last
year and this year no services are cut
we've kept a very steady line and indeed
we've increased it so I think a lot of
credit goes to the finance team as
screamy mentioned as well and what's
wonderful I think is that we can use
this money for our communities and if
they think it's important that we do
that we don't just stash all the
reserves I understand we need to have a
strong reserve and I think that's
absolutely right but we also need to
recognize lots of things and obviously
in my community portfolio I'm gonna be
asking for for certain monies for
certain things that will benefit the
communities and I'm sure my portfolio
holders will be doing exactly the same
whether that be the in business raiser
and all sorts of ways but I think it's a
it's a good budget and it's a very
positive thing going forward as well
thank you so yeah I agree and it's a
very good position for the forthcoming
year and and despite the projected
shortfall over the medium-term period
I'm sure that one way or another we will
be able to bridge that gap and we're on
we're on a sound footing and we're in
good hands anyone else councillor aathi
only really to say that I think somebody
ought to say that we haven't got very
much to talk about today and that's
because there's about three months of
hard work gone on before today there's
been a lot of discussion a lot of debate
as as Derek has said a lot of help from
the finance team to get to where we are
which is a good place as you've said
we've got we got there thank you
anyone else well I propose the
recommendations would anyone may have a
seconder castle Davis all those in favor
of the general fund budget
thank you okay moving on then the next
item is paper BCA 1935 the housing the
revenue come down to budget for 2020 to
2021 and the longer term outlook okay
again as with the general fund budget I
don't propose to go through the full
report that I've got here I'll save that
for Council but there are some slight
changes since the last time we looked at
this most notably the fact that Appendix
B now has a full 30 year business plan
and details of that attached which is is
useful because we are working on the
30-year business plan the the other
thing that in terms of our reserves
again over the 30 years we've got the
detail now and that shows a slight
reduction twelve point nine million to
twelve point six million over that
period but and with the debt repayment
profile showing all debt repaid by 2049
2050 the other main difference is that
there's an improvement of 41,000 pounds
since we last looked at it as a result
of changes to employee cost this is
rebalancing the port employee costs
between the general fund and the HRA so
we now have a surplus position of
three hundred and thirty four thousand
pounds which is obviously a significant
improvement on last year which is the
deficit of one hundred ninety three
thousand pounds so again that's all I
wish to say apart from on the capital
program that there has been a change to
the numbers of housing that we're
intending to build we were showing 229
affordable homes and I think 15 shared
ownership it's actually 156 affordable
as now and 23 for shared ownership and
that is the last time we looked the the
numbers hadn't been updated from the
previous year and we're showing the
period 2019 2020 through 2022 to 2023
as opposed to what it should be showing
as of now the period 2020 21 through to
2023 to 2024 so that's why there's a
slight change in those numbers it's not
showing a decrease in the amount of
houses we're building it's just looking
at a different period so again I would
like to propose the recommendations at
paragraph three point one to three point
nine and would anyone like to ask any
questions or make a comment on on the
HRA budget guys harathi yeah I've got a
question and it's a strange not really
because a few months ago I thought and
I'm not sure why I thought this that a
two point seven percent increase in
council house Prince was two pounds and
19 pence on average and it's actually
two past 38 and I'm not quite sure
whether I got something wrong or whether
in the early days of talking about this
the figure was different
[Music]
Catherine do you have an answer for that
I think the two prime 19 figure is the
mid Suffolk equivalent so yeah 238 is
the Weber figure thank you that was
obviously my mistake now the only other
thing to say it's really the same as I
said about the general fund I mean
there's a lot of work done into this
over the months and once again yeah
we've got there in the end
and if you need a proposal I'm happy to
to propose it well I can post being your
second yeah I'll second yeah thank you
are there any other questions castle
Davis that buzz me sorry thanks charlie
there might be too much work that's gone
into the court from me
just because you can have a graph like
that
I'm not certain actually says anything
and I have comments like that that come
up with the other reports as well I
think sometimes you're putting things
into these reports because you've got
the ability to do it even though it
doesn't tell us anything so I prefer in
my view less is more yeah I have it here
yeah and well it is what it is it's
showing graphically that there that it's
pretty stable over that period with some
minor variations there's but what are
you going to do with that information
are you gonna change any of our
decisions or our approach does it make
you feel comforted it make you sleep
well at night me I don't know just
because you can put that kind of a graph
each are arraigned future chair is it
our intention to continue with a rent
increases of CPI plus 1% or is it just
for this one year that is the intention
isn't it
Catherine I'm sorry I mean normally the
decision-making will be here on you when
we come to budget setting the standard
that the government of applied allows
councils to increase by that percentage
each year but obviously that would be a
decision taken by members year on year
based on on the actuary business plan so
at that point we've built it in at the
moment but obviously it is something
that could be change it it's part of a
pop of the current business plan because
we've got we've got increased by CPI
plus one percent for five years and the
remaining twenty five years CPI only
it just seems a shame that we're
increasing people's rent more than
inflation that may be a good reason for
it which is over a 30-year period we
need to have sufficient to repair debts
if that's the case then I guess that's
fine but it just seems a shame having
reduced their rent for the last two or
three years now to pull it up it doesn't
seem a great deal perhaps to the moat
the majority of us to pound 38 a week or
to pend 19 but by the very nature of
people that are in these council houses
there it couldn't mean quite a bit
especially if it keeps going up I'm sure
they're aware of this but just to
reiterate the point if they owned that
reduction in rent over the last four
years of course wasn't something you did
out of choice though it was imposed on
you by government the key thing is it
depends to my mind what your aspirations
are more broadly in terms of building
houses as well and because it is
effectively a single budget there's room
fenced and certainly I would subscribe
to the view that should be trying to
provide the best quality homes you
possibly can for the lowest possible
rent but that is a challenge inevitably
that's where that where that breaks in
terms of those are trying to build yet
further homes at the same time
but it's only the 1% above inflation for
five years beyond that with the business
plan is is based on inflationary rise
only okay the next item is paper PCA in
1936 joint capital investment and
treasury management strategies for 2020
into 2021 so I'm pleased to introduce
report PCA 1936 the joint capital
investment and treasury management
strategies for 2020 to 2021 this is the
second year that we are considering
separate documents but for each of these
and the for the strategy statements and
the potential indicators following the
new guidance issued by sip and the MH
CLG there are a number of appendices
here appendix a provides the capital
strategy and summarizes the capital
expenditure and financing requirements
of the full capital program for both
general fund and HRA and the details of
that provided in the budget report which
was attached as an appendix to the
general fund document earlier
so this depended sets out the capital
expenditure and capital investment
decisions and the associated risks and
rewards along with how risk is managed
for future financial sustainability the
capital expenditure for the next four
years is shown in table one of paragraph
2.3 and financing shown in table 2
paragraph 2 point 11 and these show that
the total capital expenditure planned
for 2019 2020 20 to 2021 is thirty two
point eight nine million pounds most of
this is in the general fund in which we
funded by borrowing the appendix also
includes potential indicators which
demonstrate that the investment plans
that the council has affordable prudent
and sustainable and that the decisions
are made according to good practice from
tables one four six eight and nine
illustrate the affordability and the
impact of capital expenditure decisions
and set out the both councils overall
capital and Treasury framework boring is
measured in its two beige marks the
capital financing requirement and
liability and this is shown in table six
and seven the capital financing
requirement measures the underlined need
to borrow for capital purposes this
together was a useful reserves as one of
the core drivers of both councils
treasury management activities it
measures the cumulative outstanding
amount of debt financed and this
increases with new debt finance capital
expenditure reduces with the MRP and
capital receipts used to repay debt so
Beiber's capital financing requirement
is expected increased by 21 point 3 4
million pounds to one hundred and
seventy seven point seven seven million
pounds and the outstanding debt to
increased by 15 point two five million
powers 138.236.128.7 hd480 and also the
the treasury management investment
strategy it it also includes the list of
approved investment counterparties and
the limits table one at paragraph three
point three is the key table here
showing the breakdown of the capital
financing requirement over the next four
years and it shows that both councils
have an increasing capital financing
requirement due to their capital program
and investments appendix Dean contains
the treasury management indicators which
we use to measure and manage the
council's exposure to treasury
management risks Appendix C provides
latest economic update and interest rate
forecast
and following the Bank of England
decision to hold interest rates at 0.75%
last November Island closed our treasury
advisors are now forecasting that it is
likely to remain at this level for the
foreseeable future
appendix F describes the current
investment in debt portfolio showing the
position at the 30th of November 2019 at
this point the external borrowing for
beta was 102 point five four million
pounds of which ninety six point five
four million pounds is Public Works loan
board borrowing and six point nine six
million sorry is the short-term
borrowing our investments at that point
we were thirteen point eight seven
million pounds that includes the ççla
funding circle new BS and Schroeder's
investments and we've continued the
policy of withdrawing funds from funding
circle as loans drop out and nor hope
and other that we invested any new money
in funding circle appendix G provides
the surgery management policy statement
which underpins the strategy and sets
out both councils regard to the
monitoring of risks and performance and
the primary objectives remain security
of capital then liquidity followed by
returned appendix H is a minimum revenue
provision statement which shows work
where we put aside the resources to
repay debt in later years appendix I
listed institutions making high credit
rating criteria and finally appendix J
is a glossary of terms now we have a
number of recommendations three point
one two three point eight and I would
certainly like to propose
recommendations three point one to three
point seven but I do have a problem with
recommendation three point eight which
was added by the joint audit and
Standards Committee recently I believe
that while I fully understand the
sentiment about looking at alternative
investment strategies that take greater
account of the castle's own declaration
of a climate change emergency I believe
that our primary focus on our
investments is to maximize our return so
that we've got income to to guarantee
services to to our residents also the
sentiment behind it which is perhaps to
divest from
fossil fuel companies I think is is
wrongheaded and and ignores the fact
that these companies are increasingly
becoming energy companies they are
looking at alternative sources of energy
indeed they're only these companies have
got really the wealth and the resources
to be able to exploit alternative energy
sources effectively for our future and I
can't see any of them doing anything
that would would jeopardize their their
own futures and their returns to their
investors so I think that this this
particular additional recommendation is
it's not going to offer any suitable
extra benefit to us but I'm happy to
take comments and and also any questions
from from members of the cabinet before
we go forward to propose the
recommendations gasser Aarthi it is did
we know what three point eight was
supposed to achieve because it doesn't
specifically mention energy companies it
doesn't actually mention any specific
sort of company or or areas of
investment it's just sort of like a
general thing yeah so I'm just wondering
what it there must have been a thinking
behind it that it was going to achieve a
change so what is it that somebody
thought we needed to change there was a
debate at joint auditing standards
initiated by some of the members of that
committee and the debate did focus
around a discussion of the whether
companies such as the oil companies and
gas companies were the right things for
us to be investing in going forward
I'm in it the way it's worded it says
that we should all that's all members
and working parties should be exploring
alternative investment strategies so
that implies an alternative to what
we're doing at the moment but it doesn't
actually say which bits have to change
you've just mentioned I mean I don't
know what they're getting they are they
getting their energy companies are they
getting it tobacco companies are they
getting it alcohol companies are they I
mean what are they talking about our
pension fund at what sort of investments
are they talking about is it a general
type of thing or are they actually
aiming on something specific that we do
which they don't want us to do anymore I
think from the nature of the debate of
audit standards it was the letter but if
I go back to what I was saying earlier
about appendix B which outlines our
investment strategy that and the comment
I made that that particular appendix
explains how each investment contributes
to the council's priorities and their
security liquidity and risk it also what
was the other thing I mentioned sorry if
I can just just bear with me a second
we're going to have to look for this
doing that if I could just say I mean if
the example you gave I think you have an
energy company if I could mention one
shell you know they used to be seen as
as an oil company and they're now an
energy company so they're looking at all
sorts of yes because they want to stay
in the market if people aren't burning
fossil fuels anymore so they're looking
at renewables they're looking at
alternatives so does that make them a
responsible company or an irresponsible
company and should we even be making
that judgment when we're when we're
looking at the investment strategy I'm
not quite sure all III agree with with
what you're saying Karthi and and what
the I found out the comment I wanted to
refer to the primary objectives remain
security of capital liquidity and return
so I don't see that we should adopt any
different strategy than that Kessler
Parker then in council Busby
Castle Busbee I think the simple thing
you said it the prime our major concern
is returned and I think what this motion
is trying to suggest is that there
should be another item that we take take
into account which is climate change and
it give you an example in planning we
try and press the developers to build
the kind of houses that are going to be
good for the climate energy neutral etc
if they adopted the same approach to
their investments that you're suggesting
we do they're gonna say no that that
doesn't give us the best return we want
to build these houses which don't comply
with your requirements on climate change
in terms if we want other companies that
we deal with to follow that principle we
should be doing that ourselves what I'm
saying I think is that there are there's
another aspect to investment other than
return that we now need to take into
account and I think that's not a it's
not very cleverly worded but I think you
drop the word alternative it suggests
that we should look at items for
investment that will deal with the
chaulk climate change emergency yeah I
agree both of those I'm not happy with
the wording of this a 3.8 but the more
general question is do we have a list of
if not banned investment for example do
we have a list there we don't invest in
gambling companies or arms manufacturers
or anything like that and if so where
can that be found okay Katherine can you
answer
the problem we have with this area and
it's probably mostly relates to our
pooled funds because we have investment
in pool funds that have shares in a wide
range of companies so it's very
difficult for us to be specific if we
want to invest into that port fund to
say don't invest our money in in a
particular company so I think that might
have been the area of investments that
during audience standards were trying to
trying to address but it's a we we don't
hold lists of absolutely every single
company that the pool funds we invest in
you know who they who they've got shares
in so I think that that was sort of the
issue that they were trying to address
with this and saying perhaps we should
consider that element more in terms of
where we invest the money and future if
that helps Thank You castle hope you go
to me they're just words and words
without any real meaning I just find it
as others have said that you look at it
and what does it mean is it defined in
any way no it's not the others have
obvious meanings to them and I'm more
than happy to support the idea of
removing three-point-nine I just don't
see why it's there thank you
does anyone have any questions or
comments on any other aspect of this
paper castle Parker thank Jeff just a
technicality actually and I picked up in
respect of 3.10 appendix B 3.10 ladies
investment in a hotel and restaurant on
the council so not not that it's
material to to finances particularly but
I notice that it says in here that we're
looking at a 24-year lease of a building
develops known by the council whereas
every document that's come forward thus
far with regards to that particular
development is 25 years so I'm just
curious to know why that's why that's
changed not as I say not that it's
material to to the finances particularly
but it's just a technical point thank
you thank you
offer do you want to just in the absence
of ebony because she's not here today so
just to confirm it needs 24 years it may
even be 24 years and 364 days I think
from memory but I'd love to go away and
check that happy to give you a detailed
answer outside of the room as to the
reason thank you
are there any other questions anyone
Kathir Aarthi yeah they're just really
to know what we're gonna do about this
some three-point-eight was it or
whatever are we going to reword it I
mean I think there's a little bit of
sympathy for the sentiment behind it but
nobody seems to think that it works and
it's and it's currently worded form so
are you proposing that we just delete it
or are you suggesting that we try and
accommodate it by changing the words I
had proposed not including it at all but
offer did anything simply say that so I
think good based on the conversations
that you've been having I wasn't
actually expecting anyone in the room to
move it's based on basically the
conversation you had and therefore you
wouldn't even need to vote on that you
simply be movie moving the the other
recommendations not that particular one
having said that there is some sentiment
I think within the room to the notion of
making sure that our investments are
ethical and that our investments are
mindful of the impacts in relation to
the climate and so without moving a
specific recommendation certainly that's
something that officers can take away
and we can have the conversations taking
to the point that Katherine still raised
earlier is to how we might go about
doing that we may need to go and give
that further thought we'll take that
away without you needing to formally put
a motion
sorry my microphone wasn't on moving on
and so that's been approved the next
item is paid pedometers reply to lease
question about the 25 years in the 24
years 364 days be included in the
minutes of this please I would suggest
not doing that but I'm having to make
sure there is circulated to all members
okay thank you please next item paper
BCA 1937 business rates discount policy
recent government business rate
discounts were temporary measures and
local billing authorities how to use
their discretion discretionary relief
powers to grant relief the government
reimburses local authorities for their
local share of the discretionary relief
using a grant under section 31 of
government Act 2003 last year we
approved the introduction of a local
discretionary retail discount policy to
implement these an appendix saying
contains our current business rate
relief policy which lists the types of
business at eligible for relief the
governor announced further changes to
business rate discounts in the Queen's
speech on the 19th of December 2019 and
it stated that will increase the retail
discount from one-third to 50% and
includes cinemas and music venues within
the scheme he proposed extending the
duration of the local newspaper discount
and finally it introduced an additional
discount for pubs at the time of writing
this report no further details have been
provided by the government it is assumed
that due to the temporary nature of
these discounts local billing
authorities will again be asked to use
their discretionary power to implement
these discard changes there is a short
timescale to introduce these discounts
from the 1st of April the next financial
year so that they are included on the
business rates bills issued for 2020 to
2021 the shared revenues partnership is
currently due to issue the bills on the
11th of March there are three options
open to us listed in paragraphs 2.1 to
2.3 of your report but to meet this
timeline we no need to delegate
authority for the final decision-making
ie option 1 so I'd like to propose the
recommendation at paragraph 3.1 of the
report that cabinet gives authority to
the assistant director corporate
resources in consultation with the
cabinet members of finance and the
leader to agree a local discretionary
discount the pubs update the rita
current retail discount policy and
extend the local newspaper disco once
the government has provided full details
of the schemes
does anyone have any questions
council halt
questions no statement really just
comment I think options is very welcome
it's not in the detail that we would
want as in it's not a full review and I
think most business out there will
welcome any help they can get I think we
do need to see obviously a full
[Music]
revaluation of the whole business rates
operation but obviously that's something
hopefully the government will come to in
the near future so I'm more than happy
to support its recommendation in let the
officers get this done as soon as
possible
but as I say I think it's a small step
but there's a lot more needs to be done
by government in this matter
thank you anything from anyone else okay
may have a second if for this castle
halt all those in favor thank you right
the next item is paper BCA 1938 and
that's the outputs for the 2019 to 2023
to support the delivery of the joint
corporate plan I'm pleased to introduce
report BCA 1938 the 2019 to 2023 outputs
to support the joint corporate plans
this report sets out the key outputs
that we propose for that four-year
period these outputs support the
delivery of the six strategic priorities
in the joint corporate plan agreed by
the Council in October we believe their
successful delivery will take us a long
way to always relight realizing our
vision for Baber and mid Suffolk as it's
a joint corporate plan to be places with
great communities with bright and
healthy futures that everybody is proud
to call home each of the six priorities
are supported by their own strategies
with the environment strategy currently
under development and being influenced
by the member working group and the
well-being strategy scheduled for
development in the coming months we will
also be referred refreshing our economic
development strategy over the next few
months these strategies will set out the
key outcomes under
theme and will be underpinned by
detailed action plans you'll see that
the outputs for 2019 to 2020 include
detail in year milestones more detailed
plans for these proposals for delivering
the period 2020 to 2023 will be worked
up over the coming months and will form
part part of action plans to accompany
each strategy we want to emphasize that
the outputs identified at this station
not exhaustive and we expect to add to
these over the next few years and indeed
today following discussions with with
mid Suffolk I would like to add five
additional outputs to the
recommendations and you have those in
the addendum that's sitting in front of
you now these in the main build on work
that has already started but needs
further development just to summarize
these are to promote sustainable new
homes across the district by increasing
the available advice address fuel
poverty while improving energy
efficiency and reducing carbon emissions
improve tree cover across the district
improve democratic engagement with our
residents and finally to review and
improve the planning enforcement
activity we also recognize the role of
effective program and project management
in a successful delivery of these
outputs and program boards chaired by
the chief executive understand the
strategic Director have been established
to monitor the progress of projects take
an overview of interdependencies between
projects and address the risks barriers
and resource implications a new project
management approach has been developed
over the last year more than 60 staff
are currently taking part in project
management trainee monitoring and
reporting on the delivery that corporate
plans outputs will take place in a
number of ways corporate performance
indicators are currently being revised
for 2020 2021 onwards to align with a
new corporate plan progress on the plan
will be reported in monster through the
quarterly performance reports to cabinet
ongoing reporting will take place at a
regular cabinet portfolio holder
meetings with assistant directors and
corporate managers internal audit will
continue to ensure that relevant
controls are in place reported the joint
audit and Standards Committee the
detailed list of intended outputs in
this report will enable the overview and
scrutiny
Mittie to identify key areas for further
exploration well in advance when did the
when developing their own forward plans
there finally we recommend or we
recognize sorry the importance of all
member engagement in the corporate plan
outputs and this comes back to the
recommendation foot from joint OB and
scrutiny and that an all member briefing
session will take place in March 2020 to
provide an opportunity for members to
gain a greater overall understanding of
the sticks six strategic priorities and
the strategies that will underpin these
thereafter throughout the year or member
briefing sessions will be themed to
cover one strategic priority each this
will enable all members to be involved
in more depth ongoing dialogue with the
cabinet members and officers about the
individual strategies action plans
projects and performance for each of the
six priority areas I therefore move the
recommendation to paragraph three point
one that cabinet has recommended to
agree the outputs of 2019 to 2023 set
out at appendix one of the main report
and also the five additional outputs
listed a paragraph one point two of the
addendum report I now open it up to
questions or comments from cabinet
members anything from anyone caster
Aarthi um a couple of things really
these ones on the addendum report but
I've got a couple of lays laughing
beside me and I got a couple of issues
and their to do with the planning
portfolio perhaps not surprisingly the
first one is promote sustainable new
homes across the district that's
absolutely fine but who put by
increasing available advice because
that's not actually the way that you
achieve that there's nothing wrong with
increasing available advice I support
that too but if all we're gonna do is
increase advice that might not actually
lead to any more sustainable or more
homes that are sustainable so I'm not
quite sure about that so perhaps it
ought to stop after district so it just
says promote a sustainable new
across the district and you could
perhaps say including increasing the
available advice or something like that
the next one I've got a bit of an issue
with again is planning portfolio is one
point two five review and improve
planning enforcement's now I'm all for
improving planning enforcement and I'm
doing my best to improve it but one of
the problems that you've got is actually
how do you measure that improvement do
you measure it by the number of cases
we're dealing with and therefore getting
rid of some cases is an improvement do
you measure it by the number of
prosecutions or notices surfed or
something like that is that's an
improvement so I'm not quite sure how
you would would measure improvement in
planning enforcement the review is being
undertaken fairly fairly obviously but I
really don't know how any how anybody
thought that they were going to measure
this improvement it's just like
somebody's put in improved because hey
we want to improve everything don't we
I've got first the author I'd like to
come back on that then I've got old
Cathy sorry was it and then I've got
councillor Holton in Castle Parker so
first of all in terms of reviewing and
improving the planning enforcement and
as you know Phyllis Bell is and working
and through an improvement plan at the
moment and as part of that and he is
looking at in some ways in which he can
measure and that improvement whether
it's a reduction in complaints and
whether it's some other measures of an
increased satisfaction and from amongst
members and others so any fell will be
is looking at that and at the moment the
thing that I'm not quite sure about is
that we're actually stating here that
we're going to improve planning
enforcement and I hope we're going to
improve the way it's done so I hope
that there are going to be improvements
within the planning enforcement team
that's improvements in the way that the
service is delivered if you like but I'm
just not quite sure how you would
measure the sort of that what are the
outputs from the enforcement team I'm
not quite sure how you how you would
measure that and yeah I can't really you
just gave an example which I didn't
agree with which I think was the
reduction in the number of places that
is not necessarily or complaints that's
not necessarily an improvement it's just
a reduction in the number of complaints
so I'm not quite sure about that so
trying to assist as you already pointed
out essentially this work is already
underway so in some respects adding it
to the list on one level doesn't do an
awful lot because that review and that
improvement work is underway I'll come
back to the word improve in a moment the
key thing and the reason for suggesting
that it should be added here though is
that is of such importance to all
councillors and is regularly part of my
inbox from councillors and that it
should sit alongside those other
strategic corporate outputs that you see
on the on the wider list and that it has
therefore of such weight if you like for
councillors that it's right and proper
we're not suggesting it improve all
services because that's so generic and
pointless that we wouldn't for one
minutes just adding that on that this
one we thought we took the view was of
such significance it should be added in
terms of improvements without cheating I
will throw the ball back slightly to
Kasparov the in terms of as he says it's
it's within his portfolio I think the
challenge is exactly that is to
determine what the right indicators are
that will help all casters determined
that there has been in the improvement
but I suspect all councillors will agree
that there should be an improvement so
that the challenge is not whether or not
the word appears but absolutely and I we
argue it's not one indicator it will be
a suite of indicators because as you say
to simply see a reduction number of
complaints could be triggered by a whole
host of reasons not least you could
withdraw the service and people can't
complain because doesn't exist equally
it could be greater enforcement activity
but that isn't necessary
a sign of success in that regard having
to take more enforcement in some
respects as a sign failure because we're
having to intervene more often success
to my mind is compliance with planning
without us needing to take further
actions which is a cultural change but
the one bit I would just add what while
I'm talking is of course and members are
aware of this is taking us are carrying
out building works ahead of seeking
planning permission of course he's not
not an offense you're allowed to do that
the system allows you to do that I'm
sure counselors and I would agree that
that's a nonsense but that is the system
that we have and the assumption is that
you have to apply for client permission
before you do something that isn't
actually the case so that that does
demonstrate the challenge in terms of
your first point you asked also about
the promoting sustainable homes and the
wording itself comes to you via mid
Suffolk via the opposition groups so
these proposals were alongside a further
five proposals that we'll put forward
five of them were already in your list
so you'd already determined that there
were things that you wanted to do and so
they they're already in the appendix and
the other five are close to things that
you're already doing but add a little
bit extra context but particularly in
relation to that one for example our
assessment as officers at the moment is
that the the detail of as to what was
being proposed wouldn't work but the
sentiment was the right thing and so
effectively what we wanted to include
was the sentiment and then go away and
do further work to establish well what
is the activity that will actually
deliver this this ambition oh it's it's
not only just in giving advice it's
actually so you know I don't get very
well worded but if it's mid suffix
wording and if it's the one that we've
got to go with then so--but I suppose
the same thing applies to one to five at
the only thing that I would say about
your response is that we're not doing
the review to make things worse so I
think it's blatantly obvious that the
review is to improve the situation my
question was about how you actually
measure that improvement which is a lot
more difficult so in my book of course
we're doing the review to make things
better but to say that we're actually
reviewing and in
we're reviewing and the intention is
that things will get better but review
and improved to me has got a sort of a
measurable achievement on it and I know
that Phil is is hoping to be able to use
a variety of statistics to show a short
of a direction of travel that there is
no one statistic that that tells you
whether enforcement is getting better or
worse whether it's good or bad I think
that's absolutely correct the other the
other element I would add is that
another form of measure and again a
challenge to actually measure it but
doesn't mean it's not right is for
example confidence in the planning
system overall and enforcement is only
one component of that but again a
greater confidence from our residents
that in the planning system in the
quality of the planning system the
quality of the decisions and the
reasoning says in my own decisions
enforcement forms one part of that
perhaps they agreed with the point which
is working out what the appropriate
measures are and it is a suite of
measures to help determine are we
genuinely making improvements is the
challenge but that doesn't mean you
don't try to prove them Castle whole
yeah again this is always been imposed
and less by me to suffer
you've got the cabinet member for
planning who obviously knew nothing
about these and this question quite
rightly we've got not got the
environment cabinet member here so god
knows if she knows about them
obviously Jonesy you're here whether you
knew about this but it 11th there we've
just given these additions they're
lovely words again wonderful meanings
but the cabinet members not aware of it
do we really need these put in here
these the corporate plan has been
discussed with all the cabinet members
in the past we've gone through it quite
thoroughly and yet these are thrust upon
us like this I just don't see it I'm
sorry we've got our corporate plan there
lovely words fantastic but I don't like
the way it's done I just feel as though
these are chucked in you at the last
minute we just meant to sign them off no
debate no comment I know we can do this
now but it's not really the place to be
doing it
I'd say yes welcome to the joys of joint
working with me to counsel so I agree
entirely you do not have to sign up to
these these we wouldn't want to do is
present you in a position where by mid
Suffolk has agreed something and you
weren't aware that they'd agreed it so
to speak and that's why it's come to you
relatively eleventh-hour totally accept
that Castle Parker thank jet so my beef
is and thank you it's the chief exec
who's defending this manfully but my
beef with this particularly is they're
just as previously they just badly drawn
and and in a previous life I was a I was
a union rep years ago and we were always
taught if you're gonna raise a proposal
make it absolutely clear and concise
what they mean and you know Lord alone
knows we taking our FAC quite rightly
from our constituents that we often talk
gobbledygook and and to my mind this is
it's not clear so just from a technical
perspective I think they've actually out
of order yeah I don't I don't disagree
with with the sentiment of them I'm not
opposed to them in that respect but what
do they mean I mean one point two point
to address fuel poverty while improving
energy efficiency and reducing carbon
that's not one out but at least three
outputs so it's just purely down to
technicalities for me and and I think I
think they could be drawn better frankly
yeah I have a lot of sympathy with that
sentiment counselor and from my point of
view the one that I have a lot of
problems with is one point two point
four the in democratic engagement it's
something we're doing all the time
anyway as you well know in your
portfolio and it's it's it's too woolly
as a way in the way it's currently
phrased but yes
Castle Park yeah well just to endorse
exactly that I mean that's exactly what
I've got written down in my notes here
that is actually already part of the
customer
transformation' work and that that is an
ongoing piece of work and certainly as
as as portfolio holder for Bobba
District Council I am determined that it
will be as clear and as transparent as
it can possibly be and and I'm sorry but
these aren't it a fairly no Castle Busby
after thank you for the thanks for
trying to defend them about equally
quite happy not to defend them in the
sense that they're not mine
they don't made suffix and they're not
equally they're not them it's our
administration's opposition's but just
by way of context and we've not given
you all this context partly because this
is beta this is not mid Suffolk but it's
probably useful because the points been
raised the opposition have put these
forward within mid Suffolk deliberately
in a semi woolly fashion and certainly
in an unco stood fashion because they
were putting them forward for proposals
to have discussion with the
administration in mid Suffolk and didn't
want to go to the effort of working them
out fully if they were non starters
these are the ones which are
supplementary to what you already have
within your outputs and there is a 26
page document which sets out to enthrone
between officers trying to understand
what we think might be meant by these
and setting out a great long list of
questions that officers have as to what
does it mean this what could we do
instead so for example just as a tiny
tiny example there is a more detailed
proposal that sits below the democratic
engagement one which isn't something
that mid Suffolk is currently doing and
isn't something that Baber is currently
doing which is the creation of a Youth
Council and as officers we have
questioned whether or not that's the
right approach more broadly and actually
if you're going to do democratic
engagement and I would argue there is a
huge amount more democratic engagement
we could do above and beyond what we
currently do that's not to criticize
what we currently do is just the fact
that it's a never-ending challenge if
you like that we could adopt so I would
come back to the point what will be
useful for officers to understand is
that if there is sentiment amongst these
that you would support and I'm not
suggesting for one minute you endorsed
them within the recommendations tonight
but if there is sentiment amongst these
five that you endorse then we will
continue
to engage you in those discussions as to
what that could look like and if in due
course that comes back to specific
recommendations well then we can put
that back in front of you if it doesn't
then they will be mid stuff of things
and not paper things and that is
perfectly fine you are of course
sovereign councils thank you before I go
to catch the buzz between councillor
Davis so I I have a lot of sympathy with
what's been discussed so far because
they are very very broad brush and a lot
of the detail hasn't been put into these
and and that concerns me because it
seems to me that their entry points for
the mid Suffolk opposition to take
control of the corporate plan which is
essentially a joint corporate plan put
together by the two administrations and
and if we deviate from that then we're
losing the purpose of what this is
anyway Castle Busby chair at one point
two point three surely if we do nothing
tree cover will improve as trees grow so
we can tick that one off I think we've
done level one point two point five
tribe I think I would see something
alumni we reduce the average number of
days to deliver a conclusive outcome
could be a measure just a thought I saw
one point two point four is is that a
personal objective leader
a personal objective are you suggesting
that this is this cabinet and leadership
does not engage we do and far more than
we ever have done in the past you you
will know that before the election last
year I went on the rounds around the
district question-and-answer session is
something which I fully intend to
resurrect again our communications with
with the press and with our residents
have improved dramatically so in terms
of personal objective I don't have a
problem with that I just have a problem
with with what but it's trying to
achieve and what it could open us up to
in the future anyway castle Davis and
then councillor yeah I think obviously
it's your recommendation so it's
entirely up to you had to do it but I
totally endorse what my colleagues have
said no or so agree with what the
chippings second team has said in terms
of you know we I think we should vote on
the original paper and and not have the
addendums in there and if there is a
later stage where we look at to recover
engagement or whatever then that could
come back to us later when it's actually
you know Ito but yeah but it's well it's
done properly
no disrespect whoever's done this in a
hurry but it's it's not acceptable and I
think that one of the points here as
well and I totally understand the
dilemma for offices having to do joint
working but you know I think sometimes
it needs to do to realize that we are
two separate councils we need to be
treated as two separate councils and too
many times you see reports that are for
Baber
we've been mid Suffolk in it I'm not
going to go into specifics but this is
quite often where this confusion so
there needs to be a way of officers
understanding we are two separate
councils and I appreciate this the joint
paper Bert
I think you should have certainly be
better briefed people before this has
come forward and certainly we we should
have done as well so you recommend but
you know where I'm coming from
hey you casa casa hole yeah like to say
going I think we should leave these
behind park them to one side I think is
the individual cabinet members if these
falling into your portfolio and you
think there's any merit in them and that
the suggestion in these phrases aren't
already being done then possibly take it
forward but I'd like to think trance me
up a half of you all but certainly those
who hear that by what's been said these
have been done anyway so talking to one
side if is any mirror in it then come
back but I would not be willing to
support that castle Rafi yeah I don't
want to lie to the point but I just
wanted to explore a little bit further
way they've actually come from because
I'm looking here at 9.1 it says both
cabinets and the senior leadership team
have worked closely together to develop
the outputs set out in this report which
I think was absolutely true these
deliberations have been informed by the
engagement and consultation that has
taken place in the development of the
council's existing recently adopted
strategies the joint local plan the
visions for Prosperity in Sudbury stone
market don't know I had Liam Needham
market that sorry okay well just in case
anybody would what I'm trying to say
thank you what I'm trying to say is that
we've now got five here and it seems to
me they've just been jumped on us by the
opposition of mid Suffolk they haven't
been worked on closely together by both
cabinets and the senior leadership team
and they have not been informed by
engagement and consultation
I agree with that get down Arthur do you
want to come on well I was I was gonna
agree with that entirely and he's
exactly as you just read out so but just
to give you again the detail as to where
they came from they have come through
the opposition in mid Suffolk putting
forward alternative budget proposals not
an alternative budget but alternative
budget proposals of things that they
would like to see happen and they've
also come as a result of both leaders
also mid suffix leader submitting the
outputs specifically for scrutiny to
review as well because the outputs went
to a joint scrutiny committee and so the
opposition have taken the forward the
opportunity to speak to the leader in an
engaging way appreciate him that the
politics in mid Suffolk is different
which is a critical factor and therefore
have put forward a list of I believe ten
suggestions and as I said earlier five
of those were actually already within
the outputs and therefore have been
effectively dismissed but not dismissed
out of hand dismissed because they're
already in your own jointly agreed
outputs and five were not and that the
leader am in Suffolk was happy that
those are areas that she would like to
see worked up and therefore they're
simply before you because if so that
you're aware that if officers are
working away on that we need that
clarity because we are absolutely clear
coming back to Council Davis's point
we're absolutely clearly to two separate
councils don't be under any illusions
that we're not but clearly and working
that up whether we're working up out for
one council or whether we're working up
for the two council school that's simply
that thank you all that right well
unless anyone has any further comment or
questions then I think the the general
view of a cabinet is that we go back to
the original recommendation that cabinet
is recommended to agree the outputs of
2019 to 2023 set out of Appendix 1 of
this report with no further additions so
I propose that recommendation may have a
second to please Castle halt all those
in favor
thank you right and okay everyone that
brings us to the end of our meeting next
meeting Thursday 12th of March 2020 at
9:30 a.m. the morning meeting thank you
everyone